[Applause]
all right thank you thanks for coming
here it's impressive to to work on
something that so many people like in
use
today's topic is vyas code the first
second we're not seeing slides yet but
I'll start talking yet
my name is Johannes I like mountain
biking and programming I work for
Microsoft out of Zurich in Switzerland
and my role is to look out for
performance that doesn't mean that I do
the performance that means I make
performance visible and I seat the
performance brain into people's head and
so just to put this in context so this
is the the startup so you type code dot
if you're cooler or where's the double
click an icon and then an editor comes
up and for us the the guiding and golden
principle was always to get to a
blinking cursor as fast as possible and
to keep the cursor blinking which means
like to keep the editor responsive for
the whole time so that means no
extension can can like steal CPU from
you that you're never able to type and
then in the worst case safe exit and
restart so this is our guiding principle
this talk will be the first second so it
will be about this data obvious code
that does not mean that we are not
caring about all the other seconds we
care equally maybe even more about all
the other seconds so last year for
instance we spend a lot of time to
completely rewrite how we internally
represent text in the editor such that
you can open like very very large files
and still everything works
currently we're working on on replacing
the tree widget there will be this thing
here on the side expect the blog post
soon we are like deep int you like
throwing everything out and bringing
something new in but nevertheless
today's topic is the very first second
and we want to emphasize this because
startup performance is apart from the
usual bragging rights that you get with
performance work startup performance is
the thing that nobody can escape from
right every single user of the
application on which we have millions
will experience the startup performance
so if that is not good the first
impression is already bad and you don't
want that so this is why why startup
performance is important
and this is what I want to talk about it
because I think it's not it's not very
complicated it's the sum of many little
things it's a lot of diligence that you
need and so I hope that at the end of
this talk everybody can take something
home to improve sort of performance of
electron apps before I dive in a short
trip down memory lane
beers code did not start as vias code
this code started as an experiment all
the way back in late 2011 and the
mission was to do developer tools that
run inside a web browser that make you
forget that you were inside a browser so
very early on so this is the very first
release that we did in October 2011 we
had an editor the clean editor it could
do a colorization and scroll and work
place completions and then we turned
this into something that we call the
Minako workbench it's a little bit more
similar to what you know today so you
have files that you can browse you can
actually type in them you can save them
and I can read code so we were actually
using this one already to sell for like
two or three months into the project
those two things on the Left what they
have in common is that they were running
inside a web browser so we were not
targeting electron or like a client-side
a desktop installable app we were really
targeting the web and only later like
roughly four and a half years ago we
turned that into an electron app and an
inside this was very beneficial for
performance because we were always
developing with the web mindset and it
is slightly different because you're a
lot more resources where you're trying
to do things more optimized maybe you
have a different approach to things
then then building a locally installed
app like for instance and a web app you
really count the HTTP requests that we
do because you call mmm there's like an
overhead and it cost money and a local
yep you would never go like how often do
we go to the disk and how expenses if it
is it to go to the disk right but turns
out that's something you should do what
I don't want to talk about is so it's
like absolute values there's no point in
saying obvious code is very fast there's
no point in saying burst code is very
slow because that's it's a lot of
personal opinion so if you come from
sublime obviously
slower than sublime were obviously
faster than eclipse so these absolute
measures they are they're very hard to
they're good to like talk at the bar
over a beer but they're not they're very
hard to put in numbers what I do want to
talk about and I'm very happy that
Francisco already mentioned this before
is a measure of measure measure measure
and monitor because you're not doing
performance if you're not measuring
because by default performance is
invisible right it is it is not like if
you have a programming error the
compiler might catch it or the linter
might say okay this is invalid syntax
you're a bad programmer if the compiler
doesn't catch it then the runtime will
throw you an error with respect race is
like hey in this line you are a bad
programmer like with runtime performance
this doesn't happen right it is a
computer and wants to compute things so
if you for work at it it would happily
do it so if you actually want to make
your performance visible you have to
measure it and you have to monitor your
measurements and I want to show a little
bit how we do this this will be
complicated because I see on that screen
what I'm showing so my mouse movements
might be a little bit weird so the first
thing that you should use and totally
get yourself familiar with is all these
tools that ship with electron the ship
with a browser that means they're very
well documented the internet is full of
Docs and videos how to use these things
get up your game learn how to use them
and learn how to really analyze the
performance of something especially the
performance tab gives you a whole
holistic image of everything that's
happening from loading resources to
executing JavaScript code to parsing
HTML to rendering and relay outing this
is something you cannot escape if you
want to work on performance and I like
to compare this to a debugger because it
is something that is tightly integrated
with the runtime and that gives you very
good insights about your application but
then how you use it is also how you
would use a debugger usually when you're
working on a particular feature you're
doing this one thing and you want to see
what is the performance characteristics
but it is it's not something that you
would do like every day to measure the
startup performance of your application
because it's like a little bit maybe too
much detail and a little bit too much
work to get into it and so what is the
poor man's debugging at least what is my
opponents debugging is console.log
statements and we actually have very
something very similar for vyas code
we call these perf marks and you can see
our code is like littered with these
things where we just say hey perf dot
mark and then we give it a name like
there's no rules how these names should
be we have a little bit of a will and
dip thing but in essence what this does
it takes the string data now result and
then puts it into a long array and and
then this data is just being collected
over the life of vias code and then then
you can use this data so what we do here
is we have this developer starter
performance so this view is basically
driven by that data so all the like nice
tables and like I don't know copy
phrasing T copy paste for any data for
for excel is all here and this is good
for you as the developer if you were
like hey this startup was a little bit
slower and then like if you're familiar
with the product you kind of know where
you should look for and this is
something that we use a lot but then it
doesn't help much if this stays always
on your computer because then you're
always measuring your own computer and
if you really want a money to a
performance you have to you have to do
something more so it comes the scary
world of telemetry comes it comes on to
the table because like this data we're
sending off to Microsoft and and then we
are reasoning about it it is less scary
than it sounds I want to show for once
that you can really see every single
data piece that we send so what you do
is you set your lock level to trace I've
already done that and then you have a
telemetry view here and then you see
every single telemetry event that we are
sending out and you can see here that
for instance we did send timers the
elapsed panel that we store was 26
milliseconds so took on startup to 26
milliseconds to restore this piece of
the UI and that data we then take and
put it into a a data digestant system
and then we render fancy bas on it and
you can see that sometime around middle
of October we actually had a pretty
severe regression and the performance of
this it went from an average about 15
milliseconds to 300 so something was was
not so good and this is something we
didn't immediately catch while the
safest thing because the output panel is
not something we spend a lot of time in
on our usually workflows but then the
graph could show us
the good thing is if you look here on
the the left we have a target if
something is inside us or not inside us
so I don't know if everybody knows this
vias coat comes in two versions there is
the or it's my dog there's the blue
version that most people might know the
blue version is the one that ships every
month there's what we call the stable
version and then there's the green
version that's the daily build and
that's for instance the version of use
code that we use internally as a team to
self host and also many other thousand
people that help us getting features out
in a good way and helping us to this
color box so everyone here I encourage
you to use the green version of es code
because that's the biggest single thing
you can do to help us in five bucks so
with with that in mind we have we have
our reports like this so you can see in
the insiders the green version we had
the performance regression and if you go
to stable you see the stable is always
between 25 and 30 milliseconds so we
could see this based on real data that
there's a performance problem then you
can drill in and then you can make a fix
so there you're not shipping this to
millions of people but then this this
telemetry thing or this thing is not
something you would use for development
because there's so much data there's a
little bit of a delay until all the data
suggested so you want something maybe
hey I made a change yesterday house
performance today and for that we do
have a little performance canary I need
to bring it over to the other screen so
our performance canary is there's this
little computer it doesn't look like a
canary it's my it's my very first thing
pet that I got when I drove Microsoft
seven years ago and it is slightly
dusted but we hand measured this that it
can start beers code in 1.8 seconds and
so what it does it sleeps and then a few
times a day it wakes up it don't know
its latest inside us so the green
version of this code and then it just
starts up ten times and it tries to get
under 1.8 millisecond 1.8 seconds within
these one time eight times ten times and
if it doesn't or if it does it will tell
us sending a slack message it's good we
understand
so you can see we have
the windows10 canary and it goes like
best out of 10 starts actually two
seconds so it gives us the hanky and
says everything is slow which is
actually true we are currently pulling
in some new changes which didn't make
obvious coat a little bit slower so now
now this is a bad thing but the good
thing is that we are aware of it right
now we can make a conscious decision how
to handle this situation because
otherwise you maybe wouldn't notice
because you come in the office in the
morning and you work on a feature like
you're not everyday have the 200
milliseconds bone activated to sell too
many seconds I can feel it right and
then this is like discuss you know like
then we have a discussion around it
that's the dev team right we go like hey
look the canary was complaining and it's
actually complaining is that since a few
days already but this gives us the way
to talk about performance it's like hey
we're for regression what do we do do we
unroll the change do we live with it do
we communicate transparently hey in the
next series we might not be as fast as
usual but we're working on it
so the whole point is you have to make
the performance visible and then you can
make it informed decision because by
default it is hidden this brings me back
to my slides yeah so measure a measure
measure measure again a measure against
the baseline so you measure against the
baseline at the baseline is not you
competitor product that's only for
vanity the baseline is yourself at a
previous state right you you measure how
fast Emma you make a change you measure
again if it's faster it's a good change
if it's slow at the batching is that
simple and you do that continuously
because performance is nothing that you
do on Mondays and not again during the
whole month right performance is
something performance this is the
feature of every single feature in your
product so it's something that you
continually do right and then obviously
you have to react because measuring
doesn't make anything faster just make
things visible and let's get a little
bit more real about measuring so a
typical electron startup this is a
proportion of vias code would be would
be like this so there's some time
getting ready this is electron waking up
and starting a main process and then a
render process and then basically you
have an empty window and then you can do
stuff right the first thing you need to
do is you need to load your code because
your app cannot
without code right that's the whole
point and then like we don't care much
about electron there's like smart people
working on electron and electron is
always getting better and faster v8 is
always getting better and faster so we
focus on on the bits on the right
loading code and getting to the app and
the reality of this is that you have a
waterfall so you're getting ready then
you're loading code and then you are
running your app so the waterfall means
you're actually from here to all the way
down there you're not doing anything
which is waiting right and so whenever I
have you have a waterfall which is very
common in the performance on the runtime
behavior because it's very nice to do
something then you have a well-defined
state you do something else you have a
well-defined State if you cannot avoid a
waterfall like this you cannot avoid you
have to make sure the steps and the
waterfall as short as possible so you
have to make sure that code loading is
as fast as possible and that is the I
said there's no single big thing but
actually fast code loading is the golden
hammer of performance there's a lot to
gain by making sure your code loads as
fast as possible and that is the the
next slide so I did bring a shirt so
this code itself is roughly composed out
of 1,300 typescript files and in the
development version we just load them
one by one into the into the renderer to
like do build vias code right so that
means we are roughly spending one
millisecond per file getting it into the
into the renderer which honestly I think
is pretty fast right from the disk into
the VM one millisecond profile is not
it's not bad but overall it is quite it
is quite so it's the biggest single
chunk of code loading and then what you
do and this is like a web technique and
as I said earlier we have like a web
background this is like everybody does
that that develops web apps you bundle
your code so instead of 1000 files you
create a single file and there is tools
for it so vias code uses AMD because
we're a little bit older than the modern
things we have our own bundler but if
you want to start today you would use
probably roll up layers or web pack so
in essence there's options for tools
that take many files and then they
generate a single file out of it and by
doing that you are almost saving of 450
million
right which is it's actually not 450
it's roughly 400 milliseconds so you
configure a tool to put all files into
one file and then loading is already a
lot faster you see it's only roughly a
second left right then the next step is
you enable minification so minification
is the process of ripping out comments
ripping out whitespace and rewriting all
those very nice variable names that you
came up with very short names that makes
the code just a lot more compact and in
the web world this is typically done for
like a faster load like a faster fetch
from the server but it actually helps
even on a locally machine like I
measured this on this computer it has an
SSD and it's a fast machine right and it
it you can see it's a it helps to
improve it
by more than 100 milliseconds and it's
literally just like a setting and in
some config file you say minification
true and then you gain this much right
so that's I think the lowest hanging
piece of performance that you can get to
when you have bundling already enabled
the last thing it might need a little
bit more explanation is a v8 v8 cache
data that's something you have only
because you run locally or it's
something you can only control because
you run locally chrome did this for v8
and they use it internally for websites
if you are no tab or an electron up you
can control it cache data is is the
thing since this convention that earlier
that you know like you always start with
source code like there's no ahead of
time compilation is always just-in-time
compilation and so that your source code
has like various steps of intermediate
representation some syntax tree - like a
like intermediate language to the hot
code and you can ask v8 to just dump one
of these intermediate states for you
they call it cache data so you create a
script in the VM then at a point you say
like hey please correct me cache starter
you get a binary blow up like a giant
chunk of data you put it to disk the
next time you load the same script you
just pass along those cache data bits
and everything is magically faster and
you can see we're using that and from
almost 900 milliseconds we are down to
like 520 milliseconds and that helps a
lot with performance there's a no module
it's called a v8 compiler cache that
does everything for you it hooks into
the require call and just dust this you
can also drive it
newly this is what we have picked
because we're still like in the AMD
world it's a very simple API on no Trias
we basically say create cache data and
then you have it and that is something
that that chrome is a browser that's
behind the scenes but us an electron app
you can do that by yourself
and then all in all we managed to not
load for 1.5 seconds but for like 500
milliseconds there all the sources
obvious code which is a which is the
single biggest saving you can do right
because otherwise it's more like you
shave of 10 milliseconds here and 50
milliseconds there then we're not done
there's a few things that are in italics
that means obvious code is not doing
them but you should do them the one core
thing is called tree shaking that's a
modern thing I also imagine you're
depending on a on a node module that
brings 42 functions but you're only
using five of these functions
traditionally you would ship all the
other function as well in your product
which just makes you ship more files you
have to load more files tree shaking you
know it shakes the tree so basically
copies all functions over that you're
actually truly using or symbols that
you're actually truly using and the rest
will be not in your bundle so that means
the bundle is a lot smaller everything
is faster and then the other thing is
code splitting that's the opposite of
bundling so you might figure out that
after you have bundled everything the
files actually rather large and then you
can split it up into maybe two files or
five files it depends a little bit on
your feature so if instance let's say
you have a feature that is really not
needed for startup then you can put that
into its own source file and only load
that on demand this code is actually not
doing that anymore we did that in the
web times then we weren't doing it very
right and then we got always overly
excited a little bit and then we removed
it and we run the process of bringing it
back so fast code loading is the golden
hammer of performance that's where you
should spend most of time there's the
biggest gain but there's more and like
now we're in the face like once you're
done with fast code loading or once
you're done with measuring and
identifying the real big issues in your
code then you're getting off into a face
which requires diligence where you can
shave off ten milliseconds here 20
milliseconds there and that doesn't
sound impressive you don't get a lot of
walls in the stand-up but if you shave
off 10 millisecond
ten times you have shaved off 100
miliseconds and that is already a lot
right so that brings me to all the small
things that we do and I brought two
pictures this like before and after
pictures always good to have that to
compare so that is screenshots from
views code starting this is an older
version there's a newer version and it
was roughly taking at the same time and
you can see on the left there's no text
yet on the right there's text but not
yet colors but that's okay and what's
going on there it's not that we made the
edit to a faster file loading faster we
just cleaned up things and we call that
lifecycle phases so we said the golden
guiding in principle is you want to get
to a blinking cursor as fast as possible
and behind the scenes there's many
things going on in views code that you
might be not even see on startups that
we have with a contribution mechanism
some internal API where like some random
command might register like the whole
source control integration framework
were register and like in this world it
was kind of like wild wild west we would
all like kick them off at the same time
and then they would do their things
right and it's a little bit like a
traffic jam then actually getting the
text to render I would be delayed
because it would be stuck behind some
other operation that you're not
perceiving because they happen in the
background so what we actually did a
life cycle phase is actually a nice word
for adding a waterfall so I just said
before waterfall is bad but then
sometimes the waterfall is good because
you have a well-defined state you say I
first want to make sure the Explorer and
the editor is initialized and then I do
the things that are not super super
important like for instance are getting
the gate viewlet populated because you
might want to do that after the cursor
is blinking and the code is very simple
I can I can quickly show that it's not
so impressive
we have oops we have a life cycle and
then we defined something like hey we
are starting we are ready we have been
restored restore means the Explorer is
there and the editor is is there and
then we have something which eventually
which means there will happen at one
point in the future and there you can
see if if you do a ref sir
ready there's many very few people
saying I want to work on red unready
there's many people saying I want to do
my stuff when I'm restored and just by
that like we didn't make anything faster
we just reordered things in a smart way
that everything appears to be fast that
we assigned a priority it's like when
you go to a restaurant you order they're
not starting with with dessert before
they start preparing the dessert and
they are not bringing you the bill
before they have served you food and
they're not cleaning the kitchen before
they start cooking and you have to think
about it in the same way so if you
define a lifecycle with like concrete
steps when when what should happen you
can make things appear faster because
they run in the in the foreseen order
then there's a there's another thing
where it falls into the same category
you're making something faster by not
making it faster but by running it at a
more favorable time and this is a new
kid on the block I'm sorry the wrong
tool and this is Idol called X it's a
new experimental feature and and web
browsers chrome has it Firefox has it so
that means almost every web browser has
it
it also means electron has it and the
idea of a idol callback is you can
compare to a set timeout callback or a
requestanimationframe called egg so
you're calling this function it would
return a handle so you can say cancel I
look callback but the idea is the
browser might predict that it has some
slack time and then it calls it calls
your callback with a deadline and the
debt I might say hey I have 10
milliseconds remaining if you want to do
something better do it now and that
doesn't make anything faster but it it
allows you to use the like the void when
your application starts because there's
often like the users not actually using
it yet and then you have like 10
milliseconds to create something that
you would otherwise either create on
startup which means startup is slower
and then like the current the normal
technique is you do everything at
startup because that's just how it works
right they saw your program may be a way
to start a problem then you start doing
things lazy so you said like or there's
one object which takes 20 milliseconds
to instantiate I I make it lazy so in
the getter I basically say new object
and then you may start up faster but
you made a guarantee that the first
access will be slow right because you're
doing it own event and you have many of
these things and you can use an idle
callback to select oh I got some 20
milliseconds to spare so we'll create
this object so that's something we
discovered this summer there's a very
cool blog post from Phillip Walton he is
an engineer on chromium and working for
Google I believe so he takes this thing
to town and he builds like Idol values
and Idol cues so you should really read
that blog post and get going there's
also no module
it's called idolize where you can do
these things I think for me this was
like an eye-opener that there's a canoe
trick in the back to spread our work
more evenly instead of doing everything
at once or on demand then the last thing
I want to mention is perceived
performance so often people say that's
cheating
so perceived performance is the process
of making something appear as fast even
though it's not fast right so you're not
making it faster battery reducing the
time it takes like code loading you're
not making something faster by making it
at a running this at a more favorable
time like reduce the traffic jam you're
actually cheating actually running extra
cycles to make something appear as fast
and we do that India's code I admit and
I think it's not cheating I think it's
just good UI and I want to walk you
through the sequence what happens when
you click on a tab and because we have
some time I can demo this live and semi
live so I press here if I find my cursor
hello oh yeah there you go so I want to
press package or JSON and I want to get
that text file to load right so what you
cannot see I use my finger and I press
the touch and you know there's like
these two things right there's mouse
there's free things there's mouse click
there's mouse down and there's mouse up
right so if you're not a gamer who can
click like in five milliseconds you're
most likely like releasing the mouse
button only like after 100 or 200
milliseconds right so what we do is I
trust me I'm fingers down where's my
mouse
so I wear this is weird
all right there so I press and now
release right so what we do we do all
the things on Mouse down instead of
Mouse up that makes it feel a lot faster
right
we cannot do it in all places because
sometimes with drag-and-drop it's too
complicated to get it right but in this
scenario we have gotten it right and
this is the important scenario and
that's that's how we do it but there's
actually a lot more happen that was not
visible so I did bring a little video
that kind of shows what we did so we
have the state so the right circle means
I'm just clicking down and so okay now I
have pressed you can see the tap already
says okay I'm active so you have to feel
him wow this was so fast right
but like the breadcrumbs is updated but
the context is that it's still the old
file right nobody noticed right like
regions are completely cheating right
and we do that so yeah actually we could
wait for the file to load and and you
know that is usually fast because this
is not a very big file we could for a
very big file we do that for back very
big file we would start showing a
progress by here load like a gigabyte
but like for these small files and most
files are like in the range of I don't
know small we actually pretend haste
there right and only then if I go here
and only then we actually actually come
in only then we do the file right now
the problem was this was actually super
fast and we would also not load the
colors we would present you the file
just in black and white and then after
that we start to like tokenize it and
said like oh this is say Jason string
and that needs this color and a Jason
value string is that color right so we
also do that lazy that helps a lot with
just perceiving something as fast and I
think that's not cheating I think this
is just a very nice UI pattern to give
people it's a lot smoother because what
would happen if we say like we do on on
Mouse app so it feels already slower
then we're not doing anything because we
still need to load and colorize the file
so we would stare into like an empty
white hole right and that just makes it
feel slow so we're doing these little
tricks and we do that with tokenization
we do that when you start up the edit or
very early on we just show you like this
activity bar and the status bar and like
the like the outline of the tool before
we have loaded code it's like a little
bit like server-side rendering and we
just make it appear as fast which i
think is it's a very good technique
because you have to do some work and if
you cannot make it faster you can make
it appear as faster this brings me
almost to the end if I find back to
PowerPoint this general yeah so the past
and future you have to make performance
visible it is not visible by default
performance is something that happens
all the time
whenever you do a feed feature you
should have a checklist is it accessible
is it tested as it were documented is it
fast
whatever fast means is it like did you
consider performance right so this is
something that never stops it's just the
constant theme it's the feature of every
single feature you can make things
faster by actually making them faster as
we've seen with Cote loading you can
make things not faster but appear faster
by running them in the right order so by
giving assigning some priority or like
by avoiding a big traffic jam so that
means like running things at the right
time and also I mean don't run it at all
right then since I didn't talk about
extensions but extensions don't run in
this process we have a separate process
so there they can do whatever they want
you know it's that kindergarten they can
do crazy things they will not impact the
blinking cursor right it's the golden
rule of use code and then yeah repeat
like it's always the same thing right
you always work on performance and work
on a feature then check it's fast right
or measure the performance and see if
there's anything you can shave off and
once the big things out of the way it is
just a lot of diligence there's like a
lot of small things you might shave off
only like 5 milliseconds 10 milliseconds
here but all these little things they
add up right it's the it's the opposite
of death by thousand paper cuts so
there's many many little things that you
can do and you will figure them out by
yourself because you measure and then
you can make things faster and by
reducing 5 milliseconds here 10 there
you will be faster overall and I wish
everybody happy coding and I
very thankful for you all guys being
here listening
[Applause]